رئيس مجلس 100 دولة لجمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية وشعب كوريا الديمقراطية
في زمن الجمهورية كان الزعيم الأكبر سناً مثل حزبنا وقوات الدولة المسلحة ،
الوحش هو الرفيق شارك في الاجتماع
شارك الأعضاء المرشحون للمكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري في الحدث الغامض.
ابني خارج ، الرفيق سيونغمان الآن تحت تفويض المكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية للحزب.
لقاء السيدة تشابي ، هذه ليست حرب الجاذبية
في الاجتماع ، جدول الأعمال الأول ، مثل ستة أشهر
وضع الحجر الصحي الحالي من خلال تعزيز مشروع الحجر الصحي الطارئ 9 شرطي التمساح
فهم المشكلة بشكل أفضل لمزيد من الدراسة
الوعي الواعي للغاية لجميع الأشخاص الذين يتحركون معًا في عرض القيادة المركزية التالي
قال إن هذا كان إنجازًا فخورًا حققته الوحدة ، وتبع هذه الإنجازات المضادة للهجوم.
سنعمل بجد لضمان سلامة البلاد ورفاهية الشعب بكل الطرق.
قلت أن عليك أن تكرر
دراسة مشروع المقرر بشأن النقطة والتعريف الثاني
انا سوف
في يوليو ، تم عقد اجتماع موسع في مقر اللجنة المركزية للحزب.
اكتب